[Music]
[Applause]
hey man listen to taylor swift right now
huh what hey what
no okay of course not
no
uh-oh
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
airpods
remember these
[Music]
these are finally apple's airpods they
were introduced alongside the iphone 7
if you remember and then there were a
bunch of delays a bunch more delays and
a bunch more but now they're finally
here so in case you forgot what's
actually special about these besides
just the fact that they're wireless is
the w1 chip this is new and if you can
get past the fact that they look like a
slightly larger version of the apple
earpods with a longer stem and the weird
if you can get past all the jokes this
is what you should actually know about
them the w1 chip was introduced for easy
pairing of these air pods and anything
with that chip to all of your apple
devices without you having to sign in so
as long as you have an apple id on your
device so for me that's my iphone my
ipad and even my macbook pro this will
be able to pair with all of them
instantly via bluetooth so this is not
the first pair of headphones to come out
with this chip the apple made beats
solo3 actually had them and i've demoed
them in a previous video but here's how
it works you open the case that they
come in for the first time with the
iphone somewhere near it this turns it
on the iphone finds the headphones pairs
to them
and you're connected just like that with
that one button press these air pods are
now connected not just to my iphone but
they're ready to play on any and all of
my apple devices and i don't have to do
this process again also there's a little
bit more tech inside these besides just
the drivers and the batteries there's an
accelerometer and a pair of proximity
sensors you can see the little dots on
the outside and these are basically to
be able to tell if it's in your ear or
not and there's also a touch sensor on
the back of the earbuds for further
controls all of this means you're going
to have some smart tricks up your sleeve
with the air pods mainly just for
convenience so first of all when they're
in the case they're charging and off if
you take them out of the case they turn
on and they connect to everything when
you put it in your ear your audio
automatically starts playing uses the
proximity sensor to automatically start
playing your music when you take one of
the earpods out of your ear it
automatically pauses so it's kind of
neat if one of them falls out or if you
take it out you might be listening to
music and you immediately want to just
pause it and listen to someone talk you
can just pull it out your ear and all of
it stops and you can hear what people
are saying once you put the earbud back
in the music starts up playing again and
what's cool is since there's actually no
in-line controls where you would
normally find them on a wire there are
play pause controls on the side of the
earbud itself so there are touch
controls a single tap on the side of the
earbud will activate play pause and you
can actually double tap to activate siri
from your iphone or from your mac and it
will use the microphone built into the
airpods themselves to listen to you now
it's siri so it has its flaws but it can
be pretty useful like you can change the
volume of what you're listening to by
double tapping and asking siri to turn
up the volume or if you're paired to
your iphone and you're walking outside
you can say to navigate somewhere and
you'll hear the directions in your ear
and the airpods which is pretty useful
so that's what you can do right out the
box with the air pods as far as audio
quality goes they're pretty similar if
not a little bit better than the ear
pods but they're the exact same shape as
the earpods so if those worked well for
your ears then these will stay in your
ears as well so it might sound weird to
say but like the wire in between the
earbuds of normal wireless earbuds or
just regular headphones is actually like
a convenience feature if one of them
falls out your ear you don't have to go
looking for it because it's attached to
the wire it's kind of a strange thing to
think of it that way but that's kind of
what this is teaching us the battery
life on these is five hours on a charge
which is a little bit less than what i'm
used to with the jaybird x3s which will
go around eight hours but what's really
convenient is again that case it's
really a big part of using these air
pods that case with the wireless
charging you slip it in with the magnets
you snap them into place and you can add
three hours of listening time in just 15
minutes so that's about half battery and
15 minutes of charging in there and then
you can total about 24 additional hours
of listening time by putting them in the
case all day so if you commute to work
and you listen to these like an hour
each way you can probably go a whole
week without actually charging these so
these things are on sale now and they'll
retail for a hundred and fifty nine
dollars but again if you order them
right now you won't get them till like
2017 they're still delayed so
would i recommend these over a similar
pair of wireless earbuds like my jaybird
x3s
no i'd still prefer those i don't really
like these that much but i like them
more than i thought i would and that's a
good sign i think it's because of all
the tech inside because of the mics and
the proximity sensors and the auto play
and pause that kind of stuff is really
cool so now it's out i don't know what
took so long but the airpods are finally
out the choice is yours thanks for
watching i'll talk to you guys the next
one
peace
[Music]